i'll never understand when it comes to
china and and
we've really gone off course from from
from crowder but it's fascinating how
this conversation evolves
i want to get rid of exactly i'll never
understand when it comes to china
being a kid of of the 80s i'm older than
you we just talked about ages earlier
we always treated the soviet union like
an enemy
we we were told the communist is a
communism and is it
an evil belief uh communists
don't want our our best intentions they
our enemy
we never moved our factories there right
but when it came to china we were like
communists are bad
but i mean you can make all of our dvd
players and our cars and now our wind
turbines and our solar panels and
basically everything that is sold on
amazon and 95 of our
yeah of our pharmaceutical industry and
and i'll never understand why we got
into bed with the communists because we
always knew communism was an evil belief
was it was that nixon
he opened up china to trade yeah yeah as
opposed to saying no they're no better
than the soviets
they look different but they are just as
evil because communism
is evil didn't we we treated cuba that
way we never said cuba's bad
but you know what like why don't we move
all of our like sugar cane production
there
but we did with china and it will always
remain fascinating to me and
and that is not a partisan issue because
bush did it clinton did it
uh uh another bush did it you know we
all watched
china rise but we never had this fear of
china that we did with the russians and
people will say wow the fear of the
russians was
overblown it was exaggerated but we were
we we were
we believed as a country that communism
was evil it is
and and and but not one of china is like
a weird neo-communist
capitalist amalgamation yeah probably
we're using the wrong word when we call
them communists
we have authoritarians defaulted to
authoritarian but like maybe there's a
new
socio-political movement or structure
that could be named and
china has enacted it i i don't want to
offend our our good communist viewers by
besmirching the good name of
course locally absolutely by
just kidding but all right in the family
communism and
community socialism and the country
capitalism
i would i always put it like this like
left libertarianism
which is like communism you know at its
core ideology
only works when it's like a handful of
people living a farm together yeah it's
like you know i i picked up the eggs
from the chickens
would you like to share like commune
exactly
yeah it doesn't scale up because you
know that was the joke you made the
other night
this is the question i was actually
wondering when you mentioned like we
said russia the soviet union was bad
china is bad but we can still trade with
them who killed more people didn't i
didn't mao kill like substantially more
people close to 100 million
yeah that's what i thought like starting
almost double people don't even know
yeah yeah
isn't like double what stalin what the
soviet union did yeah
let's work with them exactly exactly
yeah i mean he he starved
close to 100 million of his own of his
own people
pig iron um you know about the pig iron
stuff no i've never heard of that i
don't know the full story but it was
like he he ordered everybody to melt
down their tools or whatever oh
yeah what was that about like they were
trying to make weapons i guess they were
they were
and build their infrastructure yeah and
then no one had anything with which to
cook or
to farm or to same with the sparrows
that's right
the great sparrow campaign because the
sparrows were eating the wheat and that
was the biggest predator of wheat so
they were like great kill all the
sparrows and you would get a little
badge
every time you killed a sparrow and all
the kids were taught to kill sparrows to
get
badges until the locusts came
no sparrows to eat them because there
were no sparrows to eat them and then
you know something absurd like 13
million people died that year
because there was no wheat because the
locusts destroyed all the wheat crops
and you say well this is why communists
should not be ever in control well but
hold on can't you eat the locusts
i imagine you could mill them into a
paste and you know make bread with them
or something
but they come from above i will not eat
the bugs i will not live in the pods
that's right
yeah i'm not gonna eat yeah all my
eating bugs i got no problem with eating
bugs man that's
yeah other ones you can catch i watch
these videos where it's like some dude
at the middle of nowhere and he's like
all super ripped and he's like
if you want to survive in the wild you
gotta figure out where to find water and
then he goes and like drinks muddy water
and then he's like and food and he lifts
a rock and he's like eating milk i'm
kidding
i'm half kidding but there's a lot of
these videos of like survival and
dysentery yeah here's
here are the bugs you can eat here's how
you eat them you say cook them and i'm
like
i don't care about eating bugs when
there's no other food i will i mean
whatever
yeah same you know what you do you said
you listen listen you do it you need to
do
this
we got chickens i brought it up earlier
but we have chickens they walk around
all day all they do is eat bugs yeah
and then when they're old enough they
poop out an egg yes you know and you eat
the egg
yep i don't got to eat the bugs i eat
the egg there you go problem solved
were we talking about china
transmutation matter yeah
yeah having all the locusts and uh the
problem ultimately was the command
economy yes
that's that you know it's the idea of
communism
is this utopian idea that everyone's
holding hands and everyone owns
everything and the factory just operates
and there's no hierarchy no leadership
and it's it's usually you know like
children and
and the ignorant who propose it because
they don't realize
what specialties are yeah so like you
have someone whose specialty is
building a keystone pipeline as a welder
with 25 years experience and then you're
told by quasi communist john kerry
well you can just build a solar panel
now exactly so what happens is
when somebody who actually knows how the
infrastructure of pipelines work
is seeing all of his specialists who
build pipelines
and they're told by the guy in
government make solar panels
he's like we don't know how to do that
think about how that scales up in
communism
the communist government says just have
them all make solar panels and they go
here here and they bang the gavel
and then all of a sudden a bunch of
people are like looking down at
circuitry and photovoltaic cells and
they're like
what do i what do i do i plug what in
the what and where and like
that's what now did with the farmers
right he took a bunch of like professors
and intelligentsia and moved them out to
the farms and it was like now you farm
and they were like we don't know how
and then they all starved yeah yeah in
the soviet union they used to uh
determine output by weight so they would
say how
how many nails did you produce well we
we measure output by weight
so they made really fat heavy nails and
and which are useless
right yeah they're not any good but they
were they were they were hitting the
criteria and that is the collectivist
concern i have of this administration
when it comes to tomorrow they're going
to unveil a four trillion dollar
infrastructure and jobs plan
and who's going to four trillion dollars
how long is the over how many
months or years is that coming oh i'm i
you know i wow another four trillion
we'll see it
come out tomorrow but who are these
collectivists saying yes this is what we
need
to make happen this is democratic i have
willed a train we were talking about
this earlier
from miami to seattle is on the map and
they showed you the map of going through
florida and all across
the the panel the high-speed rail with
the high-speed rail now how much land
they're gonna have to confiscate will be
absolutely fascinating
but who is this person that has decided
is there really that much of a move
from people from miami to well probably
from seattle to miami because everyone's
going to florida
um california has been trying for 10
years now to build this high-speed rail
they are a 100 billion dollars at price
point it's not even close to done it's
12 years behind schedule
and the price point is so expensive that
no one will be able to afford to take
the train well this is what happens when
collectivists decide they want to be in
charge of the train system
right vanderbilt never had this problem
and he built more darn trains in this
country than anyone in the world
and somehow he made it work take a look
at what china's doing
they've somehow managed to use the
authoritarian system to control
capitalistic infrastructure
allowing them to rapidly expand their
infrastructure they have what 40
000 kilometers of high-speed rail yeah
we can't even get this one done in
california yeah you know why because
there's no
environmental group suing to say what
about the spotted turtle
there is no labor group saying you
cannot do this we need to have uh
weekends off there's no child protection
group there's no osha
so you can get a lot done and that's
what drives me crazy when authoritarians
like paul krugman
and other economists say they marvel at
what china is able to do
this is incredible they built this whole
olympic stadium for beijing in a week
it's like well yes they were able to do
that when you have basically slave labor
with no opposition with no freedoms you
can build the birds nest in beijing in
record time
yeah it's it's amazing what you can do
as a country when you
weld people into their homes when they
get sick and you kidnap them overnight
for insulting their police
and and the the authoritarians like john
kerry and paul krugman
are never the ones who will be
conscripted to the labor
that's why when people are like bernie
sanders is a communist i would always
say he's not a communist
he is a communist party leader because
at the height of the soviet union's
misery there was never a shortage of
vodka or caviar
and that is what john kerry and paul
krugman and all these folks are they are
never the working-class nine-year-old
girl
who was forced in the labor mines they
are the party
leaders that show up in big fancy cars
and have a toast
remember when maduro ate the empanada on
tv remember that in venezuela
his nation is starving oh yeah yeah and
he's still very plump
and while he's talking he just reaches
into a drawer in his desk and
pulls out an empanada and takes a bite
of it and now i'm just like dude you
couldn't wait 10 minutes
he had to eat an empanada while his
nation's starving yeah
absolutely insane when i was in
venezuela you know what i saw
how a command economy functions very
similarly to what you're saying about
china
in order to make jobs they just say make
it a job
so i went to go buy a cell phone and
there was like six different desks you
had to go to
i walk and talk to one guy it's the
acquisitions department i got tom what
i'm looking for and he explains to me
sends me over to the the supply desk
i had to go to each individual person
you want to pick out your plan you got
to go to the person who who helps you
pick out the plan
then you got to go to the person who
actually goes and gets the card for you
then you gotta go to the person who
helps you pick out a phone
then you gotta go to the person who
actually gets the phone they made fake
jobs for the sake of having jobs
whereas in the us you walk into the
phone store this person walks up to you
say i'd like a phone no problem they
pull it up they punch in the number
take your card swipe it you're good to
go for the sake of having jobs
they just make everything worse oh
that's because a private company in the
united states
wants to cut down an overhead so they
don't hire superfluously but
the the government can just accrue tax
dollars to pay for
nonsense and then they work for me now
but it's it's not just about tax dollars
because it's it's you know communism or
whatever they're just basically like
we want everyone to be working you know
idols idle hands
playground or whatever so make them work
make jobs
and so i'm like why did it take me three
hours to buy this phone wow and a phone
barely worked yeah i went to the mall
the mall was dead it's like all the
stores are closed well
they can't just mandate you can mandate
a job for a company that's a necessity
people need cell phones
this technology is important for people
to work and for the economy to grow so
that that was in spite of what the
government was doing at a mall
where small businesses are supposed to
flourish and experiment and make
products
they couldn't they couldn't do it
because people didn't have the resources
now the craziest thing
these photos from venezuela of the
bolivar i think it's the boulevard
fuerte now
their currency because they're the
boulevard the billion dollar bills
yeah they had the bolivar first then
they were like we're going to change
this to the boulevard fuerte
and then they launched that and now
those videos are just people shoveling
into the trash
yeah it's like garbage bags full of
money and people it's like
more useful as toilet paper than
anything else that's devastating
venezuela will always fascinate me i
always have to talk about energy it's
what i do for a living but
they are the country with the world's
largest oil reserves proven oil reserves
venezuela
um they went from one of the world
leaders in oil to
now there's roughly a week wait to fill
up your car with gas
and you say how milton friedman used to
joke that if the federal government were
in charge of of the sahara desert they'd
eventually run out of sand
right it was his favorite joke and and
this is the country with the largest oil
reserves
cannot produce oil anymore it seems as
though it's intentional by the cia
because they don't want to use
opec dollars they've been staunchly
anti-military industrial complex and
like yeah we're going to destroy your
economy
suffer maybe yeah they're one of the
targets but sure but venezuela
can and then they mine can can pull the
oil out of the ground
it's like they don't have the technology
sanctioned they couldn't get like
well i heard they couldn't get toilet
paper i was never there um
and then they made a villain out of
their leader like it's it's who makes it
where does that
come from uh cia stuff the cia makes a
toilet paper
no they just sank the us government
sanctions venezuela so venezuela needs
to
if they were a capitalist economy hey
they do a really really they joined us
if they simply joined the military i'm
not saying that i'm saying if venezuela
allowed small businesses to grow and
flourish and they didn't mandate
ridiculous garbage jobs
maybe they'd have their own toilet paper
and wouldn't be worried about the
sanctions maybe they would then have the
infrastructure and the capability of
producing machines that could
harvest the oil and the petroleum and
refine it but there's kind of a small
country and they're a jungle country too
so they don't have a lot of the
resources that like a jungle country
yeah there's a lot of jungle and then so
they need to develop it the problem is
they're a mismanaged
command economy where an overweight man
eats an empanada on tv while his nation
is starving and the cia wants them gone
i i don't look man oh yeah if if my
neighbor was mad at me and he was
blocking the road
to like to my house or whatever and
there were still like tons of land on my
property and the capability of taking
care of myself
there's a certain point where you got to
be like well i shouldn't have bought a
property with no you know with no
easement for the road
venezuela has the ability the problem is
they are a horribly mismanaged
country maduro was a bus driver hugo
chavez was like
we want a working person to be in charge
so this bus driver is going to be the
president from now on we're going to be
popular
didn't venezuela dissolve their congress
or something i mean
venezuela before hugo chavez came into
power was by far the wealthiest country
in latin america and by far the most
educated i mean they were almost on par
with the united states in terms of gdp
in terms of prosperity so to watch their
decline
under someone who was elected under a
lot of the same rhetoric we hear
fair share the rich get richer the poor
get poorer when i'm in charge we're
going to have a blah blah blah
and people going back to the one of the
earlier conversations
people vote for their own interests and
if you make their interest
taking other people's prosperity wealth
absolving your debt people are going to
vote for that oh it's possible because
bush and that's what happened bush hated
chavez yeah
junior and and just because he he was
military industrial complex all the way
they wanted venezuela's oil
so maybe maduro was kind of like a cia
plant they got him in and now they're
villainizing him
to make it they let him ruin the country
now now they're like we got to get him
out and put another guy in that's even
more sympathetic to him this is all
conspiracy level stuff
yeah but it's all we talk about the cia
and their involvement
and we just we're never going to know we
understand the
the tales of economic hitmen yeah we
know about all that stuff but
the fact of the matter remains i have
been to venezuela
i've literally seen how awfully managed
the country is
i have seen other journalists go there
and go to potemkin supermarkets and lie
about the food they have luke went there
he went to
a random neighborhood market he's like
it's empty he traveled around and saw
how bad it was
and his journalists come out these
videos where they're like look at all
this glorious food in venezuela and it's
like
clearly that's not true i had to flee
the country rather quickly
because i got accused of being a spy
simply for being there and showing
people what was really going on
there were protests students were
revolting it was bad
caracas at the time was the murder
capital of the world
this is a problem of leadership and i
get it
maybe there's the cia doing everything
their power to stop them but listen
if they're a jungle nation maybe they
should start developing parts of their
country
it used to be that people would go out
with a saw and just chop trees down and
develop land
then we got machinery maybe they can't
get access to a lot of these things but
it doesn't explain why they have
ridiculous jobs or ridiculous companies
why they can't start small businesses
where they can't produce food and they
have all of this oil
they don't know how to use properly now
apparently oil is cheap for the people
there
but it's really hard to get because
they're horribly mismanaged well when
you're shoveling your
your currency into the fireplace it
doesn't matter if it's cheap right
right i mean if it costs 45 cents a
gallon you say well that's cheap
but but if hyperinflation makes your
currency useless well then 45 cents is
is is as expensive as four dollars and
also hyperinflation is
is is obviously their fault it's it is
the fault of
their own country they're reacting so if
i'm not going to call it reacting it's
it's mismanagement bro so communists
don't
it doesn't work now i'll tell you this
china's certainly figured it out but
look at what china does
with their capitalistic enterprises
venezuela doesn't do that
they have a command economy maybe they'd
learn if they just looked at what china
was doing and they could make their
pseudo-communism work but i guess that
wouldn't really be they're
so tiny that's their problem they're
kind of a satellite state
i feel like it's not an excuse for our
country to be like but but america is
mean to us
it's like so you have to
like you're responsible for yourself man
you can't complain it someone else won't
send you toilet paper i'm coming i'm
curious to see what happens with china
as their crackdown on hong kong
continues
because it is a huge economic engine
it's a world economic
engine a financial hub um there and
they're
they're really cracking down hard on
hong kong and if if hong kong is unable
to compete on
on a financial world level in freedom
i wonder what that does the overall
chinese economy i mean like like taking
over hong kong hard has been a 20-year
plan
since the turnover which i think was
like january 1st 2000 right wasn't it
right at the beginning of the
millennial was when when the millennia
when when
the uk gave up hong kong i don't
remember the exact date and there was
like a certain time frame
there was a certain time frame and and
here we are 20 years later and basically
that even
i'm sure the buy administration would
recognize the word on the street is for
the expats is
don't stay in hong kong it's kind of
crazy hong kong
was a british colony and then they were
like after 100 years i think it was
we're going to give it back to china
china's like we're going to take hong
kong but we're not going to infringe on
some of their sovereignty
although they did by extraditing
criminals to the chinese courts is
that's like
but hong kong's never supposed to be
independent that was never part of the
deal so this whole like free hong kong
thing is not what was ever part of the
global plan
the u.s is pushing it right now because
everyone i think a lot of americans
would love to see a
independent hong kong state but the idea
was the british give it to the chinese
terrifying as it is that was the plan
are we gonna what are we gonna back out
on that
um what year do we live in 2021 where
thank you thank you
where a country the uk can be like we
are going to
give the people of this you know small
island still a colonization plan or
pennsylvania they still have
australia and canada britain that's
crazy but what i'm saying is like
if what would happen right now if the uk
was like we're going to give america
to canada we'd be like shut your mouth
that's just not happening
and so what really happens is china
sends in
spies and propagandists and military and
they
conquered hong kong they did they
install their people
they remove anyone who opposes them and
now they're just eroding away at the
institutions and hong kong will be taken
over at the administrative level
it's freakish and i can't see i mean i
feel
justice at the core of my soul and i
feel like justice
is to deliver hong kong to the chinese
as was planned
how was it because that was part of the
contract the people of hong kong didn't
agree to that contract no people 100
years ago agreed to
see how well they're all gone it's crazy
system i mean would we break the
contract
i don't think we have to stick to the
contract you know they did
the balfour declaration uh i think was
post-world war one was like
hey arabs since you betrayed the
ottomans and helped us win world war one
the british and the french were like
we're gonna we're gonna give you the
land of where now israel is and then at
the end of world war one they
they reneged on that contract and said
no arabs we're not going to give it to
you
they created the israeli state and
that's where all this tension came from
the arabs like we were supposed to have
that it was a contract
yeah i i think giving people their
freedom is always a good thing but
returning people to an evil regime is
not and so to say like we're going to
give hong kong its independence from
from the crown
i mean we got our independence from the
crown i would be in favor of that but
that would be like america saying and
now we're going to give puerto rico to
cuba
and right it's like well because you
speak the same language and you're very
close to each other
like well wait a second why why are you
sacrificing us as your people
and i feel like the british had they
were their people and they turned them
over
and they turned them over to the
communists and i mean we fought the
whole eastern bloc of
of europe was to prevent the the
uh soviet union from incringing
infringing more and more in there
you know because we realized how evil it
was and now it's like ah you can just
take it as well you know
take the czech republic it's all good
you got take austria you guys speak the
same language anyway isn't it really
funny that
two world wars in a cold war were fought
for the express purpose of stopping
one consolidation consolidated power
taking over europe
and then finally they're just like maybe
we should just do it anyway
and then the european union comes in and
there you go yeah yeah exactly
and now we're teaching all our kids
mandarin in class because we think it's
fun and it's like great we'll just
just learn learn the language of your of
your conquering overlords
hey you know get get ready for
assimilation thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you